Call your doctor today, and ask
about Prolia®.
♪.
>> I BELIEVE HIS TOP AIDE HAD
ACCIDENTALLY TOLD THE TRUTH OF
THE COVERUP.
THAT THEY PURPOSELY HID LIFE AND
DEATH INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN FEAR
THAT THAT INFORMATION COULD BE
WEAPONIZED AGAINST THEM.
EVERYTHING IS UNRAVELING.
HE IS SHAKING AND HE IS TRYING
TO ROPE EVERYONE IN INCLUDING
THE SENATE, INCLUDING THE
ASSEMBLY, AS MANY ELECTED
OFFICIALS AS POSSIBLE, INSTEAD
OF TELLING THE TRUTH TO THE
15,000 FAMILIES WHO LOST LOVED
ONES IN THE LAST 10 MONTHS IN
THIS NURSING HOME FACILITIES.
PETE: THAT NEW YORK DEMOCRAT
ASSEMBLYMAN WHO CLAIMED GOVERNOR
CUOMO THREATENED TO DESTROY HIM
FOR CRITICIZING HIS NURSING HOME
RESPONSE, SAYS HE WON’T SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR POLITICALLY ANYMORE
AS BACKLASH OVER THE CRISIS
GROWS.
JEDEDIAH: NEW YORK GOP
CONGRESSMAN TOM REED JOINS US
NOW TO REACT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR BEING
WITH US THIS MORNING.
SO THAT ASSESSMENT YOU JUST
HEARD OF WHAT CUOMO ACTUALLY IS
GOING THROUGH, DO YOU THINK IT
IS ACCURATE?
DO YOU THINK HE IS SHAKEN RIGHT
NOW?
WHAT IS ACTUALLY GOING ON BEHIND
THE SCENES IN YOUR OPINION?
>> I APPLAUD RON KIM FOR
STEPPING FORWARD.
I WOULD JOIN HIM IN THE EFFORT
TO HOLD THE GOVERNOR ACCOUNTABLE
TO COMPLETION.
IT IS EXACTLY ACCURATE.
I THINK EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED IS
WHAT HE DESCRIBED ON THE
COVERUP.
HIS NUMBERS, CUOMO’S NUMBER TWO
WENT OVER, ADMITTED THE TRUTH.
SHE CLEARLY FUMBLED IN HER
EXECUTION OF TRYING TO PUT THIS
GENIE BACK INTO THE BOTTLE.
SHE WENT OVER TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AND STATE SENATE,
ADMITTED ON TAPED CONFESSION OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY WITH
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE PERJURY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
BUT I WANT TO GO FURTHER.
I STILL WANT TO DEMAND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHY THIS
ORDER THAT KILLED 15,000 PEOPLE,
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHERE
HE ORDERED POSITIVE COVID-19
PATIENTS BACK INTO NURSING HOMES
WHERE RESIDENTS WERE NOT
INFECTED, ENDED UP BEING THE
ROOT CAUSE OF THIS THING THAT IS
GOING TO NEED TO BE FURTHER
INVESTIGATED.
WILL: REPRESENTATIVE REED, WE
TALKED TO YOU IN THE PAST.
WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY MIGHT MEAN, WHAT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE FOR GOVERNOR
CUOMO.
WHETHER REPEAL OF HIS EMERGENCY
POWERS, IMPEACHMENT, WHATEVER
MIGHT BE.
I LIVED IN NEW YORK FOR 14
YEARS.
I CAN’T TELL YOU HOW MANY PEOPLE
KICK A CAN DOWN THE ROAD TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT BILL DE BLASIO OR
COMPLAIN ABOUT GOVERNOR CUOMO.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DO IN THE
END?
THEY VOTE DEMOCRATIC.
IS THERE ANY ELECTORAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU POTENTIALLY HAVE INTEREST IN
CHALLENGING GOVERNOR CUOMO.
DOES A REPUBLICAN HAVE A SHOT TO
UNSEAT SOMEONE LIKE GOVERNOR
CUOMO?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE’RE CONSIDERING IT.
WE’VE BEEN ASKED BY MANY PEOPLE
TO DO IT FOR MONTHS.
I THINK THEY APPRECIATE THE WAY
I GOVERN, NOT GOVERNING BY
ARROGANCE AND BULLYING THAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO DOES.
TRYING TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
AS A PROUD REPUBLICAN.
I GO INTO THE ROOM WITH
DEMOCRATS.
I FOUNDED THE ONLY BIPARTISAN
GROUP OF WASHINGTON, D.C., THE
PROBLEM-SOLVERS CAUCUS.
I GO INTO THE FIGHTS, KNOWING
WHO I AM, WHAT I AM FIGHTING
FOR.
UP IN ALBANY, ONE PARTY CONTROL,
UNDER DEMOCRATIC CONTROL.
PEOPLE ARE SICK MUCH IT.
I’VE BEEN IN THE BRONX.
I’VE BEEN IN HARLEM.
I’VE BEEN INSIDE OF INNER-CITIES
IN NEW YORK CITY.
THEY ARE SAYING THE EXTREME
POLICIES COMING OUT OF ALBANY
ARE KILL KILLING THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THEY DO NOT LIKE THE ONE PARTY
CONTROL.
I AGREE WITH THEM.
IF I’M THE VOICE TO TAKE ON THE
GOVERNOR, I WILL PUT MY WORKETH
I CAN, MY REPUBLICAN IDEOLOGY I
BELIEVE IN.
BUT I’M OPEN TO BE CHALLENGED TO
INSPIRE PEOPLE TO DO IT BETTER
FOR NEW YORK AND NOT BE AFRAID
OF THE DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW
THAT THE DEMOCRATS BRING TO THE
ROOM.
THAT IS WHAT WE’LL BE LOOKING AT
AS WE GO TO CHANGE ONE PARTY
CONTROL IN AL BAN IN, NEW YORK.
WILL:
PETE: ANDREW CUOMO IF HE RUNS
AGAIN, SURVIVE TO THE BALLOT
BOX, WOULD BE RUNNING FOR A
RECORD FOURTH TERM.
SOMEONE, WHO WILL EVER
CHALLENGING HIM HAS TO BE
FORMIDABLE CONSIDERING THE
POLITICAL MACHINE HE BUILT WE
FOUND OUT RECENTLY THROUGH A LOT
OF INTIMIDATION AND NOW
COVERUPS.
WHEN WILL WHICH KNOW IF YOU’RE
GOING TO BE A CANDIDATE?
WHAT IS YOUR TIMELINE TO DECIDE?
WOULD YOU RUN ON THIS ISSUE AND
WHAT WOULD BE THE TOP TWO OR
THREE ISSUES TO RUN ON?
>> LOOK, THE NURSING HOME
SCANDAL IS NOT A POLITICAL
SCANDAL FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
I HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THIS FOR
MONTHS BECAUSE 15,000 PEOPLE
DIED.
WHEN THIS ORDER WAS ISSUED IN
MARCH 2020, WE TOLD THE GOVERNOR
DON’T DO THIS, YOU WILL KILL
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
WE HAD THE NURSING HOME
ASSOCIATION WITHIN 24 HOURS FROM
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
TELLING HIM YOU WILL KILL PEOPLE
BY DOING THIS.
THIS IS ABOUT HOLDING
ACCOUNTABLE THE GOVERNOR THIS
RECKLESS ORDER THAT HE DID,
KNOWING HE WAS GOING TO KILL
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
THEN I WATCHED HIS NUMBER TWO,
DR. ZUCKER, GIVE A PRESS
CONFERENCE THIS WEEK, AND DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE LIE THAT POLITICAL
FACT-CHECKERS WAS FALSE.
THEY WERE LISTENING TO FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS FROM THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THIS IS
WHY THEY DID WHAT THEY DID.
THAT WAS RULED FALSE MONTHS AGO
BY THE FACT-CHECKERS.
THAT TYPE OF LYING, THAT TYPE OF
ARROGANCE.
THEN DR. ZUCKER HAS THE
ARROGANCE TOO TELL 15,000 PEOPLE
THAT DECIDED THEY WOULD DO IT
EXACTLY THE SAME WAY AGAIN?
THAT TYPE OF ARROGANCE HAS TO
END.
PETE: REAL QUICK, WHEN WILL YOU
MAKE A DECISION WHETHER YOU’RE
RUNNING OR NOT?
>> WE’LL TAKE CARE OF THIS ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
WE’LL HAVE A FAMILY DISCUSSION.
THIS WILL BE A FORMAL EFFORT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THIS DECISION
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
STAY TUNED.
WE’RE IN THE FINAL POSITIONS IN
MY HOUSE BECAUSE I HAVE TO
OBVIOUSLY TALK TO MY FAMILY,
HAVE THAT FINAL OKAY, BUT I WILL
TELL YOU, WE’RE GETTING CLOSE
BECAUSE, I CAN’T STAND IT ANY
LONGER.
THIS STATE NEEDS TO COME OUT OF
ONE PARTY CONTROL.